Bonjour à tous.
Bonjour.
Hier j'étais avec la patronne. On a parlé de notre projet, « l'Homme ».
Et alors ?
Elle a kiffé !
Du coup on fait le proto, balancez vos idées, on commence.
J'ai une idée dont je suis un peu fier
c'est la main.
C'est pour attraper des trucs avec cinq doigts.
Pas mal, pas mal. Est-ce qu'il y a des griffes pour déchiqueter les proies ?
C'est trop violent, ça ! Pas des griffes !
Toi.
Euh, oui pardon.
Alors, moi j'ai...
Le nombril.
Développe, vas-y.
C'est un trou dans le ventre.
Qui fait... ?
Ah non, j'avais fini. Voilà, c'est ça...
Je verrais bien des petites bouloches qui traînent dedans.
La boss va me tuer !
Par contre moi j'ai un trou qui sert à quelque chose.
Ça sert à l'évacuation des déchets.
Admirez s'il vous plaît...
L'anus !
Non, quoi... Mais non...
Regardez, ça a un petit charme quand même !
Cache, cache-moi ça. Cache-moi ça !
Il y a des poils autour, dedans et tout !
Il y a des poils dedans ?
Mais c'est dégueulasse !
Mais t'es marrant, il faut bien qu'il y en ait un qui pense aux déchets !
Pense à des trucs qui font rêver sur l'homme, je sais pas moi !
L’œil !
Ah !
Bien vu l’œil !
J'adore !
Oui d'accord.
C'est pour voir. On en met combien ?
T'en mets un gros au milieu du visage.
Cinq. Sept ! NEUF !
On en met deux.
On va en mettre deux.
Deux c'est bien, c'est raisonnable.
Qu'est-ce que t'as ?
Oui, alors moi j'avais le pied.
C'est quoi le pied ?
C'est comme la main, mais en bas.
Oh ! Pour attraper des trucs sans se baisser, c'est bien ça !
Pour attr... Ah non ! Ça n'attrape rien.
Ça n'a pas de doigts ?
Alors si, il y a des doigts, mais trop petits pour attraper quelque chose.
On peut dire peut-être qu'à la fin de la journée, ça sent pas bon le pied.
Une main qui pue et qui n'attrape rien.
Merci.
Non mais sympa comme idée ou pas ?
Bon, moi j'avais pensé aux sourcils.
Moi j'adore ça les poils.
Ah non, ça va ! Ça va encore être de l'entretien là.
Et on n'a pas parlé des sexes.
Moi j'ai bossé sur un truc, ça s'appelle
« the vagina ».
C'est tout équipé à l'intérieur : lèvres, clitoris, système de fleurs auto-wash...
Un petit bijoux.
On comprend... que dalle.
Alors... Moi j'ai bossé aussi pas mal...
le pénis.
*rires*
C'est marrant cette forme !
C'est bien ! Avec les ronds et tout !
Si, on prend ça, le pénis.
Non mais c'est une blague ! J'ai passé la nuit sur mon vagina !
L'autre il a dessiné un pénis en deux secondes !
OK, OK ! On va prendre les deux.
On va prendre les deux, ça pour l'homme, ça pour la femme.
Avec des poils partout.
Et qui est-ce qui porte le bébé ?
Bah, l'homme !
Il faut porter des choses, c'est l'homme.
Vous êtes sûr ? Ça dure neuf mois, c'est douloureux, ça laisse des vergetures et ça fait vomir !
La femme !
D'ailleurs j'avais pensé pour nourrir le bébé avec du lait...
le téton, pour la femme.
Le téton pour la femme, oui, c'est important.
Et pourquoi pas pour les hommes ?
Ils ne font pas de lait, du coup on n'en met pas pour les hommes, ça ne sert à rien.
OK, pas pour les hommes.
On foutra deux-trois poils autour quand même peut-être, je note ça dans un coin.
Et puis j'ai un autre truc c'est...
l'aisselle !
Regardez, c'est en-dessous du bras.
J'y ai remis quelques poils mais j'ai une direction artistique.
J'imagine que ça sent mauvais à la fin de la journée ?
Oh, bonne idée, ça. Très bien.
Bon, du coup pour sentir j'avais pensé le nez.
On pourra foutre des poils là-dedans.
Avec deux trous pour respirer.
Sinon l'intestin, j'avais pensé à ça
c'est une sorte de tuyau pour traiter la nourriture.
Ah !
Ça c'est bien, c'est important.
C'est vrai on n'a pas pensé à ça pour la nourriture.
Oui, un tuyau pour la nourriture. L'intestin on le fait long comment ?
J'avais pensé comme ça.
Ah non plus petit, plus petit...
Sept, huit mètres !
C'est trop long huit mètres !
Non, non...
1m60 maxi.
Ça rentrera jamais.
C'est quoi qui rentrera jamais ?
OH !
Bonjour patronne...
Qu'est-ce qu'il est émotif...
Ça va les cons ?
Bonjour !
*grimace* « Bonjour ! »
Patronne vous avez une branche sur l'épaule.
Mais, enfin pas du tout c'est Victor !
C'est pas une branche c'est... mon phasme.
Il est adorable, regardez. Caressez-le.
Oh là ! Attention !
Qui est-ce qui a inventé cette merde ?
J'adore.
C'est hyper affectueux comme animal.
Pas bouger ! Pas bouger.
Alors, c'est quoi qui rentrera jamais ?
C'est le tuyau pour la nourriture, on disait que huit mètres ça rentre pas dans l'Homme.
Mais bien sûr que ça rentre ! On tasse !
On se démerde ! On bourre ! On embobine ! On tournicote ! On...Voilà !
On trouve des solutions !
Merci !
Quand on veut que ça rentre, ça rentre.
Et au bout du tuyau on pourrait rajouter mon fameux trou.
Non ! Non ! Non ! Cache ça !
C'est bien, ça !
C'est génial ça, trou de bal !
Oui, je pensais plutôt l'appeler « l'anus », mais pourquoi pas.
Oui, oui, c'est un anus mais c'est vous le trou de bal.
Vous êtes viré.
Par contre qui a inventé les poils ? C'est une bonne idée ça, ces petits poils partout
ces petits cheveux de taille moyenne ?
Ah, c'est vous !
Bon, eh ben c'est bien !
Vous êtes embauché.
Et vous vous êtes viré.
Chef de projet, ça vous dit ?
Et pour ce qui est des Hommes, éclatez-vous, j'adore.
Vous m'en faites de toutes les tailles, de tous les poids, toutes les couleurs...
Enfin, quand je dis toutes les couleurs, vous ne me sortez pas violet, évidemment.
C'est moche, le violet.
Ni ce bleu de merde.
Vous ne me faites pas un bleu comme ça de merde lavande, hein, vous êtes gentils.
Donc, niveau poils, je pense qu'on pouvait en mettre éventuellement sur les bras, sur les mains, sur les doigts, sur les doigts de pieds...
Au sujet des tétons...
Je pensais, je vous ai entendu en parler, il faut en mettre sur les Hommes aussi.
Parce que sinon ça fait vide, ça fait pas fini.
Allez, Victor on y va, allez.
Victor !
Vous aviez raison, c'est une branche. #Jambon à ta prochaine vidéo tu auras une p'tite surprise !!!